is it a twist-off you're given a non
twist-off bottle of beer and a piece of
paper can you open the beer using
nothing but the piece of paper your
clucking kidding me this is no problem
no issues are there any rules I can't
use anything else but these twists okay
you fold it in a way to pop open the tap
I'm gonna fold this paper to make it
strong enough to maybe be a bottle
opener oh I know [ __ ] glue does get
me wrong it's already too thick to fit
under the cap I ripped my skin on of you
could tell but nothing's happening I've
seen all these videos too and they told
it was something and saying that I would
never think of it's got to be a leverage
thing which I haven't figured out the
silence in here is just very deafening
[Music]
i'ma try one more time the papers gotten
a little bit some wear and tear that is
really hard is the paper a trick I've
already run out of videos it's ripping
through the paper that's not good it's
also hurting my hand like a like I like
a champagne bottle you know if you look
like I'm trying to will this to open
what if I work on me something a bottle
opener maybe oh oh this is it this is
totally it y'all hear that [ __ ] oh yeah
oh I'm gonna get it I give up I'm done
fine I give up show me how to do it show
me a little trick I don't know I don't
know I don't know I think it's over can
I just drink it now glorious
oh [ __ ] yeah that's the right way to do
it
[Music]
fold the paper in half vertically and
continue folding in half until you can
no longer fold the paper then fold the
paper horizontally forming a sturdy
wedge place the folded paper between the
knuckle of your index finger and the
groove of the cap use the leverage to
open the bottle drink up oh wow a little
looser you mother clucker I was close I
think cracking it open just a little bit
felt as good as a beer taste and it
tastes [ __ ] delicious
[Music]